nadège bonjour alors le départ de cet
acte 63 était prévue à 13 heures les
gilets jaunes sont ils au rendez vous
[Musique]
alors les gie les jeunes qui sont en
aurons des fous ils sont plusieurs
centaines vg les jeunes ici pour aider
la place mireille havet et ils doivent
partir des siens poignée de minutes
maintenant parcours de 8 km vous l'avez
dit qu'il doit partir de cette place de
mireille havet pour est bien arrivé en
fin de journée dans le quartier du
viguier le parcours comprend notamment
des passages à jaurès est également
devant quartiers nord un dispositif de
sécurité a été mis en place un
dispositif assez important puisqu'on a
autour de cette place plusieurs dizaines
de véhicules de police et des crs
mobilisés pour assurer à la sécurité de
ce raid deux cortèges de cette
manifestation
le préfet de police a appelé les
manifestants à la responsabilité il a
aussi a pris un arrêté d'interdiction de
manifester pour les gilets jaunes
et bien une dizaine de mieux et
dix stratégies
notamment la centaine
une année les choses
le palais
les mises et les ministères de
l'intérieur ou encore le forum des
halles une manifestation donc qu' un
cortège qui devrait donc quitter les
lieux d'ici une poignée de secondes je
suis avec l'aco déclarante de cette
manifestation divine d'amigo bonjour
merci d'être avec nous alors
expliquez-moi un peu comment est-ce que
ces annonces c'est acte de 63 à paris
aujourd'hui
bonjour bah écoutez un peu comme tous
les autre samedi donc effectivement la
semaine dernière c'était un peu
particulier parce que c'était un appel
national
les régions sont montés en majorité même
les gilets jaunes dans les pays
frontaliers du fait des pays frontaliers
comme la belgique l'allemagne la suisse
l'espagne portugal
nous avons eu des corses nous avons eu
aussi des anglais
nous avons eu aussi le ralliement de
beaucoup de syndiqués qui sont venus ses
repas en cortège syndical parce que
malheureusement nous avons rencontré
quand même des restrictions
administratives administrative de la
part de la préfecture donc de la part de
monsieur le préfet donc il a fallu un
petit peu biaisé ce qui a donné
effectivement une forte mobilisation
hier
hier la semaine dernière par dont nous
étions plus de cent mille personnes
aujourd'hui je pense que bon on va être
à peu près dans les 1000 2000 au
démarrage est toujours très peu de
personnes mais ça finit par grossir un
petit peu faut pas oublier que toute la
semaine et citoyens se mobilisent aussi
par rapport aux grèves des autres
manifestations syndicales donc le samedi
il ya peut-être un peu moins de monde
parce que fatiguée malade aussi à une
épidémie de grippe en ce moment donc
quoi qu'il en soit on est toujours là
vous une dague bigot ça fait
plusieurs mois que vous déclarez ces
manifestations à paris qu'est ce qui
vous motive chaque samedi et bien de
déclarer à nouveau un rassemblement va
écouter nous les déclarants se met à la
disposition des citoyens qui le
souhaitent
en fait c'est pas déclarés pour déclarer
c'est pas pour avoir de la gloire ou
juste le plaisir de déambuler dans dans
paris c'est parce que beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes nous demandent de
continuer à faire pour eux parce que
beaucoup souhaitent continuer à
protester à contester notamment les
retraités notamment les personnes à
mobilité réduite qui elles se sont
retrouvés récemment à cause de la
réforme qui est sorti là le 1er décembre
dernier
imputer de 200 à 300 euros de moins par
rapport à la route surtout les personnes
qui ont 95% de handicap
personne n'en parle ils sont mal
représentés dont pour eux le seul moyen
de s'exprimer c'est de manifester
vous fustigez tout à l'heure la réaction
à des forces de police lors de l'acte 60
de la semaine dernière à paris les
heurts qui ont éclaté notamment aux
abords de la gare de l'est et la gare de
lyon un mot à ce sujet là donc au coude
discours est bien dénonce
aujourd'hui bien le fait que nous ne
serions plus en démocratie en france et
qu'une certaine forme de dictature s'est
réinstallé vous en pensez quoi de ce
sujet là emmanuel macron a pris la
parole cette semaine il a dit et ce sont
ces propos essayé la dictature et vous
verrez qu'ils viennent avec ompi qui
viennent avec nous en manifestation va
comprendre la dictature qu'il est en
train de mettre en place
en instrumentalisant les forces de
l'ordre n'oublions pas aussi qu'il a dit
lors d'une interview que la police était
là pour protéger le citoyen et lui
personne n'a relevé sa non la police
n'est pas là pour protéger le président
mais bel et bien être au service des
citoyens
donc là dessus ce lapsus est absolument
révélateur donc il est en train de dire
aux citoyens venez essayer mais la
dictature c'est quoi à la base c'est un
groupe de personnes qui comment dire qui
asservissent toute une population
qu'est ce qu'il est en train de faire
lui avec son parti politique et son
gouvernement c'est exactement la même
chose
elle est là la réalité donc oui j'ai
relevé la semaine dernière des actes de
violences policières
je ne suis pas lassé l amnistie
internationale la ligue des défenseurs
des droits de l'homme beaucoup et elle a
beaucoup ont relevé ça ddd des retraités
ont été matraquées j'ai retrouvé une
femme de 64 ans retraité qui est à
l'hôpital saint-antoine des jeunes qui
se sont fait éclater par terre ça
absolument pas normal
moi j'ai été gazé à bout portant vous
pouvez voir chez encore brûlé au cou
j'ai un problème à l'oeil je pense
certainement avoir des gros problèmes de
rétine j'ai été gazé à bout portant
c'est absolument inadmissible qu'ils ne
parlent pas de ce qu'il est en train
d'engendrer la dictature est bel et bien
en place
linda bigot merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes co
déclarante de cette manifestation de
manifestations dont qui ne devrait plus
tarder à quitter cette place mireille
avait donc pour prendre la direction du
quartier de villiers dans le 9e
arrondissement de paris merci beaucoup
de neige pour toutes ces précisions
nadège abderrazak en direct du cortège
des gilets jaunes qui doit se lancer
sans tarder